long weakness
yes
foreign
not available
goodbye
is
yes
um
oh
thank you
uh
yes
yes
thank you
hey
yeah so now my youngest
is
i um
is
hello
good morning everyone and good evening
to those watching
uh in kuwait uh dr mod it's wonderful to
be
uh with you to host you and your team
here in washington dc
uh and the foreign minister and i just
uh completed a great conversation a
productive uh gathering
and our teams have been doing the same
these annual meetings
uh each time have been more productive
than the one previously
and that's in good part because of the
goodwill of our two teams
and the important relationship between
our two countries
kuwait is one of our most important
strategic partners throughout the middle
east
and our administrations work hard to
deepen the historic bonds between our
two countries
indeed we're grateful that the ladymere
made these ties even closer once again i
want to express my condolences to the
people of kuwait
for the amir's death earlier this year
our work today honors
him builds on his proud legacy in
several key areas
he opened up new ways for us to think
and work and talk together
i want to start with a topic that's on
everyone's mind a
battle against the pandemic from wuhan
many people in america
in kuwait and around the world are
suffering because the chinese communist
party failed to properly alert the world
that it had a public health disaster on
its hands
it silenced brave chinese citizens it's
wonderful that the united states and
kuwait have been able to work together
on our preparedness to make sure we are
ready to tackle
public health challenges alongside each
other
during our dialogue just now we signed
an mou to increase our cooperation in
areas like biomedical research
and information sharing and we finalized
another mou
today between the kuwait fund and the
state department's usa
id thanks to that agreement we'll
coordinate on assistance on everything
from energy
to food security as well as two of the
most generous donor nation
countries in the world the united states
and kuwait are proud to work together
to help those in need and to save lives
on the economic front we signed last
year uh
to increase entrepreneurship and grow
small and medium-sized enterprises in
kuwait
and we're already producing success
stories it contributed
uh to the four and a half billion
dollars in bilateral trade between our
countries
in calendar year 2019.
this pandemic has put a halt to a lot of
the movement of goods and people
but i am confident i'm confident that as
we move forward we'll soon see more
trade more investment
and students and business people
traveling much more frequently between
our two countries uh finally too our
strong security relationship
next year is the 30th anniversary of
operation desert storm and the
liberation of kuwait from saddam's
bloody tyranny three decades
american kuwait relationship has been
built around security cooperation ever
since
that time today kuwait and iraq
collaborate closely and build ties to
peace
and prosperity while kuwait hosts
thousands of united states troops
who work closely with both militaries
this is the model of progress and i
thank the kuwaiti people
for the good work that they do to
support our soldiers sailors airmen
inside of kuwait our two nations are
also united on the challenges of our
time
we fought together to defeat isis
fraudulent caliphate
and we're aligned in countering the
iranian regime as well i want to thank
kuwait
for its support of the maximum pressure
campaign together we are denying tehran
money resources wealth weapons with
which
they would be able to commit terror acts
all across the region
we're working to resolve other conflicts
as well
the foreign minister and and
kuwaitis have been models in moving
forward to heal the gulf rift and their
assistance
continues to be of great importance in
that respect
and as i said last year in kuwait
president trump and i both believe the
ongoing dispute
has dragged on for too long it benefits
only our adversaries
dr matt thank you for your friendship
thank you for joining me here today
and thank you to the people of kuwait
for being true friends
of us here in the united states thank
you thank you mr secretary my dear
friend
secretary pompeo thank you so much for
hosting us and thank you so much for
hosting the fourth dialogue meeting here
in washington
i would like first to recall
the deepest appreciation from his
highness the emir
the leadership the government and people
of kuwait for all
that you have done for the late his
highness the emir
providing the mid-back airplane and all
of the health
care for the resi for the latest
highness the emir and also bestowing
upon his later the latest sign is the
emir the legion of merit
it's something that will always be
appreciative
in in kuwait also i would like to
express the great gratitude
of the leadership of kuwait for the
continuous relentless commitment
of united states in in the security
of kuwait but also of the region
and of the cooperation that we have in
this
regard as you have said your excellency
next year will mark two events important
events will mark 30 years
of the liberation of kuwait where the
united states
and the leadership of the united states
guided the coalition of 35
nations around the world in maintaining
international
security and international law law and
liberating kuwait
also it will mark 60 years office to bl
establishing diplomatic relationship
with the united states and will work
very hard for those two events to have
its
its its matter here in washington but
also there in
in kuwait the maintaining
this strategic dialogue is very uh
important
now for the past four years we see
progress
in all fields and sectors and they are
numerous and the six working groups
now have made a tremendous advance in
our bilateral relationship either
defense security
economy education health and human
rights
now with the challenges of covet your
excellency
also we think that there are some
fields and sectors uh to uh enhance our
collaboration
in them and as you have mentioned uh we
are
now in in either in in
in securing and maintaining and
enhancing and bolstering our
health institutions but also in in food
security the relationship in bilateral
relationship and since the creation of
the fourth
dialogue meeting it has given us a clear
caliber to gauge the advancement
in our relationship uh it has
institutionalized
our relationship and for for the past
four
four years for example in in
in finance we have risen our investment
to 17 in the last four four years
uh our trade also advanced uh
to uh to over 14 billion uh
from 2016 to 2020
uh the role also
of all of those who under seek
education here in the united states is
advancing in a very
clear speed and we are also very much
in support of of that now
some somewhat 90 000 equaties are
enjoying
uh the education here in
in kuwait uh we are also combating as
your excessive mentioned against
terrorism
and also enhancing our cooperation cyber
security we all we have a beautiful
story
between united states and kuwait
and we will make sure that will this
story
will even transpire even for future
generations to come
i thank you again your excellency thank
you very
mr much any comments or advice for your
successor